you know i don't forget though because
it happened to me right yesterday
just stopped by the police what do you
mean what did you do a criminal
activity that you did being wise
i'm being a minority for once
so like i was literally like okay so i'm
coming up the escalator to like
you know because in japan you have to
like ding out of the gates right yeah so
coming up to the escalator to go through
the gates and
there's like two pylons two sets and i'm
so i'm coming up the escalators i'm
going to go
forward being out and literally
hiding behind the pylon as a police
officer and look when i pass him i've
got headphones on i've got to like cap
on so like maybe i'll
[ __ ] dodgy i don't know but literally
when i pass this guy i see like
in my corner my eyes gotta jump in
action just immediately come up to me
and stop me and i'm like [ __ ] what
what have i done dude and i'm like what
what's wrong and i'm like oh so i won't
say anything in japanese i'll just
translate at all yeah
he's like oh where are you going and i'm
like um
just going home you know just chilling
out why what's up you're like oh really
cool cool can i see all your cards so
you have like a
foreigners card right yeah which or by
law you always have to have this uh
foreigner what's it called yeah
yeah yeah and he asked me if like
japanese okay i'm like yeah i can
i can speak a little bit and luckily
like everything he said i understood so
it's good
and he was like oh okay and by the way
like my like my train is in like
i think like four minutes so i'm like
come on man come on
yeah keep it up keep it up so he looks
at my cars and it says like oh i'm an
entertainer
he's like oh cool cool what do you do
i'm like oh i say uh say you which means
like voice actually
yeah yeah
like japanese teacher and i'm like what
i literally just told you
why would it be entertainer i'm just
sitting there like oh no no
no like like say you say you're like
emcee tall like yeah
yeah commercials games it's like oh
games i'm like yeah yeah games he's like
what games and i was just like i was
like
what do you want me to like you're gonna
look it up like what do you want so i'm
like oh
it's in english it's in english and he's
like oh dead ass right he goes
oh do you play apex
like he's like 40 maybe 50. dead ass
asked me if i play apex i'm just sitting
here like laughing so i'm like [ __ ]
and i [ __ ]
like two minutes two minutes and i
trained in two minutes and um
he's like oh cool you're from the uk i'm
like yeah you're from the uk uk so it's
like
and at this point i feel like ah okay
i'm kind of like i know he's not gonna
lie
yeah yeah yeah he's just talking about
yeah sounds like he's just looking for a
friend right now i don't know why he's
talking to me he doesn't say why he
stopped me he doesn't say anything like
that maybe he he was one of the japanese
dudes you played apex
maybe he he just looks at you and he's
like this guy gives off gamer
i'm gonna stop him i wonder if that guy
plays apex
and so yeah so i'm like that he's like
i'm from i think i'm from the uk
yeah yes where i'm from so you can speak
good english then
no no i thought this is all in general
he can speak he was nihongo
yeah like luckily everything he said i
either understood or understood enough
of
what he's saying right to form figure
out what he's like
he said something about something going
to uk something something marriage and
i'm like ah and i said like honeymoon
in like broke like katakana like ah
honeymoon yeah oh hi hi
so he told me that he went to the uk and
he loved it he said
arnold orki ben
he said he liked to be like big ben and
that he liked
buckingham palace he said the japanese
word for palace yeah he said that
something you then [ __ ] q there yeah
he said buckingham
q then i'm like i'm pretty sure he's
saying buckingham palace i don't like
kidding it's beautiful listen it's
beautiful
it's like yeah yeah yeah he's like yeah
i was like laughing i'm like i don't
want to laugh though because it's a
police officer
like why are you laughing because you
guys know what bing means right
what it means [ __ ]
saying i didn't know that it's like dead
ass means giant [ __ ] i mean that's
pretty [ __ ]
it's pretty [ __ ] [ __ ] big [ __ ] it's the
big [ __ ] i thought
because i thought the word for [ __ ] was
uncle no bang is another word for yeah
so yeah and then he was just like yeah i
go to
paris i'm like oh yeah you like wine
yeah me and my wife love wine i'm like
cool cool i like wine too he's like all
right yeah you can go now and i'm like
thanks man thanks make me miss my
[ __ ] train
ten minutes so you so you're dead i just
bonded with a police officer over apex
yeah luckily it was nice but like it's
pretty like alerting when you first stop
you and i'm like why are you stopping
yeah right
why are you stopping me and then someone
told me uh they were like yeah
apparently there's like um
some police officers like quotas of like
people they have to stop
oh really makes sense they've just got
so little work to do here right so
and they're normally told to i guess
they're getting paid to do something
this is like the least like xenophobic
way of like saying this but apparently
i've i've been told i don't know if this
is true
that some police officers are told to
stop uh foreigners
to practice their english i mean that
makes sense that makes sense but it
feels
wrong like if if that happened in
another country
that's [ __ ] up that's not right yeah
yeah but i mean
you know like at least they're nice
about it though right yeah i just don't
like that they asked like my id
like i don't know someone about that
feels weird i guess they check my
colleagues i think
i think that's because they're obligated
to do this yeah i think i think they
have to do that right because if they're
threatening when someone asks your ideas
i mean there's never a way
where a policeman asks for your id and
you don't at least sweat a little yeah
yeah
right like i'm like did you like the
audible like swallow like
this is literally like white guy gets
like discriminated first time in his
life
pov like this is like the story right
so this is what it feels like to be a
minority [ __ ] oh god that's this is
[ __ ] up
i'm kidding i know it's [ __ ] bad yeah
but like yeah i mean it's happened a few
times but it was because it happened at
like 10 p.m i was like
you know for some reason when it happens
at night it feels like way more like
whoa
and i'm like why are you stopping anyone
else i'm the only i'm the only non-jedi
you shouldn't have told this story on
trash days you could have easily made up
i got
my first racist experience in japan
video
i'll do it i'll do on a live stream so
the clip can come out before this part
yeah
good idea gonna get the actual brain
yeah yeah i just like i just
i started cracking up so much when he
asked me when i played apex i was like
oh my god oh my god i was like you can't
make this [ __ ] up like
i knew when i was gonna tell the story
we're gonna be like that's [ __ ] no
it actually i wish i [ __ ] this is like
this like yeah and
and everyone applaud it yeah i was like
this is too
unreal that he literally just asked me
if i play apex
when i literally like don't shout about
it's like everyone but it's really it's
really popular in japan so yeah so
massive in japan